Once you've added a site to Burp Suite Enterprise Edition, you can perform a pre-scan check to firstly,
make sure that Burp Suite Enterprise Edition can reach your target URLs,
and secondly, review your recorded login sequences.
This is so you can make sure that they log you into your sites successfully.
Burp Suite Enterprise Edition prompts you to perform a pre-scan check when you add a new site,
but you can also perform a pre-scan check on existing sites at any time.
To perform a pre-scan check, navigate to your sites page and select the site in question.
We select Run Pre-scan Check.
The pre-scan check runs the URL connection check and attempts to run your recorded login sequences where applicable.
The pre-scan check captures still images from the recorded login sequence for you to review.
We'll fast forward here to the completion of the pre-scan check.
When the pre-scan check is complete, you can review the connection check for your URLs.
You can expand the pre-scan check menu and go to the Connections Check tab to see the connection status of your target URLs.
If the check fails, you'll also see some remediation advice.
If you have a stored recorded login sequence for the site, you'll also see the recorded logins tab.
This enables you to review images from your recorded login sequences.
For more information on that, please refer to reviewing a recorded login sequence.
Thank you.